what did the first mate find in the
captain's toilet hello and welcome to
another episode of biographics I'm your
interim host Carl Smallwood that's Carl
with a K and small wood with a small and
then a wood yep I know it's very funny
let's move on and today we're talking
about Anne Bonnie history's most
infamous female pirate and as of all the
videos here on biographics this one is
based on original script submitted To Us
by a member of our writing team that
person today being Ru Alexander who you
can follow a social media links below if
you are so inclined I'm also down there
buried in the links somewhere you can
click those if you like but let's get to
it and before I continue with the video
I'd like everyone at home to just let us
know your favorite pirate joke let us
know in the comments I'll start with
mine what is a pirate favorite letter
everyone thinks it's AR but it's not
most pirates love the
sea Blackbeard Henry ever William kid
Bartholomew Roberts they were some of
the most infamous pirates in history
they've all had one thing in common they
were all covered here on biographics by
my ever illustrious and far more
aerodynamic predecessor Simon Whistler
they were also all men so they've got
two things in common we just wanted to
mention those so you can go watch the
videos if you are so inclined after you
finish watching this one that's not to
say all Pirates were men there were some
notable exceptions like over in China
you had Ching XI who became one of the
most successful pirates in all of
history and even in local Waters we have
Anne Bonnie who gave up an easy life as
the daughter of a rich Plantation owner
to follow her true calling raising the
Black Flag and sailing the Seven Seas as
a pirate
y but before that another pirate jokeer
and I've got many of these because I
love bad terrible jokes the worst the
better what's a pirate's favorite toy a
Barbie we start off with the standard
disclaimer for most of our pirate videos
biographical accounts and official
records on these scurvy Sea Dogs are
pretty scarce and detailed information
is really hard to come by most of what
we know about an Bonnie for example
comes from a single Source a rarity for
a biographics video where we like to
consult multiple sources that would be a
general history of pirates and that's
pirate py r a t s by Captain Charles
Johnson which is a pen name for an
author whose true identity we don't even
know some historians even believe it may
being Daniel defo so keep in mind that
whoever wrote it like to embellish with
dramatic effects now and then or you
know simply make stuff up taking Captain
Johnson at his word we can say that Anne
Bonnie was born in a small town near
cork in the Kingdom of Ireland her birth
dat is unknown but considering the time
she was active as a pirate it's not too
far of a stretch to believe she was born
sometime in the late 1600s from the
beginning an's life was like a soap
opera although Johnson does not give her
father a name only identifying him as
some English lawyer other sources say he
was William Cormac and his mother
however was not Mrs Cormac it was in
fact the housemid for Mr Cormac Mary
Brennan sometimes identified as Peg
Brennan we don't really put too much
stock in these names they don't really
matter what does matter though is
according to these sources the wife
suspected the affair and had it
confirmed in a rather dramatic soap
opera likee fashion One Night by
sleeping in the maid's room and waiting
for her husband who arrived in the dead
of night and made love to her in the
dark thinking it was Mary whether or not
she waited for him to finish before
confronting by ripping off the sheets or
in my version in my head she s up like
The Undertaker when he's cuddling
just like I sure hope my wife doesn't
find out but we don't really know for
sure but according to these Sorcerers
afterwards the wife tried getting some
petty revenge on the maid by setting her
up for the theft of some silver spoons
and having her arrested however by the
time of her trial Mary Brandon was
pregnant and that plus a lack of any
real solid evidence like a jilted lover
just saying hey they stole my spoons
isn't really much of a case um she
basically had her get out of jail free
card and soon after an Bonnie was born
into the world of course she wasn't born
and Bonnie but for simplicity's sake
we're just going to call her that
throughout the video because it's easier
for us and you at home to follow along
at some point the lawyer's wife passed
away and he wanted to raise Anne as his
child however everyone knew that the
maid had a daughter so instead he
dressed Anne up as a boy and pretended
that she was a son of a relation of
course this didn't really stop the
rumors from swirling and rumors turned
to Scandal when Cormac started Living
openly with his maid eventually the
lawyer concluded that the only way to
escape the vicious gossip was to just
build a new life elsewhere so the whole
family packed up and sailed across the
Atlantic relocating to the province of
Carolina so dressing his daughter up
like a boy and introducing to a sailing
at a young age I wonder how this one
became a pirate there the family settled
into Charleston where the lawyer tried
his hand at lawyering I guess for a
spell before concluding that being a
merchant was far more profitable an's
mother died at some point in the years
that followed and she became the new
woman of the house and an turned into
quite the Tomboy with a fey temper and
attitude to match Captain Johnson
mentions that on one occasion where as
he puts it quite delicately a young
fellow would have laan with her against
her will and young Anne beat him up so
badly that he was bedridden for a
considerable time Legend William kmar
proved to be a skilled and successful
Merchant and was able to afford a quite
large Plantation outside of town he
expected his daughter to marry well and
have a nice comfortable life in
Charleston but Anne had other plans when
she was she married a two- bit pirate
named James Bonny who was to quote not
worth a Gro furious with her decision
her father threw out of the house and
disowned her with employment
opportunities is a bit thin on the
ground in Charleston James and and
Bonnie set sale for the Bahamas the
pirate Haven of New Providence we can't
move on without telling you another
really bad pirate joke so do pirates
like going to strip clubs of course not
they've already got all the booty at
home ha moving
on
the Bon has arrived in the Bahama
sometimes between 1714 and 1718 we're
not really clear when it was around this
time that King George the first of Great
Britain issued the 1717 Proclamation for
the suppression of pirates better known
as the act of Grace or simply the king's
pardon this was a one-time offer of
complete clemency for all acts of piracy
to those who surrender to authorities
before a specific deadline plus a few
extra for those who turned in or helped
capture other Pirates who refused to
take the king's pardon James Bonnie took
the governor up on the offer and with
that but became an informant something
which Anne was not particularly happy
about she was all about that pirate life
and the author put it in so I'll say it
it's it's a bad joke which I do respect
but I hope this doesn't get taken out of
context at some point cuz you know what
they say once you raise the black you
never go back once you raise the black
you never go back but it didn't really
matter much to her because Anne wasn't
really enamored with James Bonny anymore
she had found a anbo Captain John rakam
better known as kico Jack so suffice to
say that Jack was a bit higher up on the
pirate pecking order than Janes Bonnie
although he too had accepted the king's
pardon he only did this to leisurely
stroll around the Bahamas without fear
reprisal from the authorities he never
really intended to abandon that pirate
life and once he'd won the heart of an
Bonnie he dressed her up as a man took
her aboard his ship and went back to
pirating and by the way if you are
curious about hearing more about kico
Jack we already have a bio on him as
mentioned hosted by my aerodynamic
predecessor so you can go watch that if
you like but cliffnotes version is is
that he assert the captaincy of the
Ranger from one Charles Vance another
notorious pirate and when he stole a
Sloop from under the nose of a Spanish
warship this all happened before he met
an Bonnie so we're not concerned with it
here but it's waiting right there below
in the description if you are so
intrigued anyway the two set sale in
early 1719 about a small but very fast
Sloop with a modest crew of just 20 men
at first an's disguise worked quite well
but soon she became pregnant and there
were some things that you can't exactly
hide even from illiterate Pirates kico
Jack's behavior in this situation was
uncharacteristic shall we say for a
supposed ruthless pirate captain and he
showed great concern and compassion
towards his pregnant Lover he knew that
a pirate ship wasn't the best place in
the world to give birth to a child so he
did arrange for a safe haen for Bonnie
in Cuba with some Close Associates of
his who would be trusted to look after
Anne and her baby and really safe isn't
the right word here and Bonnie was still
a British pirate on a Spanish Island if
she would be discovered she would have
most certainly been executed so after
she gave birth in early 1720 she
reunited with kico Jack once again
dressed as a man strangely enough she
wouldn't be the only woman in Disguise
rackam for all that long and
after an encounter with another vessel
kico Jack's crew was supplemented by a
privateer who was actually a woman named
Mary Reid passing herself off as a male
pirate just like Bonnie and eventually
Andis discovered Mary Reed's secret and
the two of of them may have become
lovers maybe and then Jack found out and
then the three of them may have also
become lovers this was a complicated to
say the least love triangle and we don't
really know the exact details of it all
we do know is that when they were
eventually captured both women claim to
be pregnant oh kico Jack you dirty old
Sea Dog anyway moving on as we mentioned
kico Jack maintained a modest crew and
relatively small time compared to his
notorious contemporaries like Blackbeard
or Henry ever he wasn't going up against
giant gallions let's just put it like
that most of his prizes consisted of
unguarded merchant ships probably his
most audacious acts during his time with
Bonnie was when they snuck into the
nassu Harper and sto a sleek and sexy
12ton Sloop named the William and used
this as his new flagship vessel this
happened on August 22nd 1720 on a dark
and stormy night rakam and a gang of
trusted Sidekicks and Bonnie among them
sailed quietly into the harbor and
bordered the William they subdued the
guards raised the anchor and set off
managing to escape nasty before the
soldiers inside the for had even
realized what had happened and now they
commanded a fast and dangerous ship like
the William rakam and Bonnie would
become true Terrors of the Caribbean SE
at least for a couple of
months before we move on it's time for
another bad pirate joke what did the
first mate find in the captain's toilet
the Captain's Log oh that's a bad one oh
that's one of our favorites so at some
point an Bonnie gave up the of being a
man we don't know if this was by choice
or if she was discovered or whatever but
it made no real difference kico Jack's
crew was so small that he could fill it
with enough Sailors who didn't really
care whether a woman was aboard the ship
or not especially when those women
proved their worth as pirates and
especially when they're dating the
captain even still Bonnie dressed like a
man during the day more for practical
purpose than anything else but at night
she was free to Don a dress or skirt
without worries and while Bonnie and
Jack were wondering what to where they
were unaware that stealing the William
had put them right at the top of the hit
list of the banian governor w Rogers who
issued a warrant for their arrest or
death which ever came first and was
cheaper we'd like to end the story with
some epic Master and Commander style
battle but real life is seldom so
accommodating the truth is that the
capture of the William was quite
anticlimactic at the end of October 1720
a pirate Hunter named Jonathan Barner
investigated an area where an
unidentified ship fired upon a passing
vessel you know they were pirates once
barut realized it was the crew of the
William he demanded their surrender the
Pirates refused of course they were
pirates so Barner opened fire with his
broadside cannons obliterating the
Williams sails and rigging completely
outmatched outnumbered and outgun the
Pirates were sitting duck so they
quickly reconsidered their position and
of course surrendered the end for Cleo
Jack and his crew was Swift and indeed
merciless they were arrested and brought
to Jamaica where they were all found
guilty of piracy and hanged just a few
weeks later at this point Bonnie hoped
that she could use her womanly Wilds to
avoid the rope and tried to claim that
Ram's crew had forced her into piracy
against her will people may have been
inclined to believe her since the idea
of a female pirate was still
unbelievable and outrageous in those
days whatever hope she did have of doing
this though were dashed when one of her
former victims a fellow woman named
Dorothy Thomas testified against her
Thomas claimed that an Bonnie was just
as much a pirate as any man she saw and
she'd witnessed Bonnie in full pirate G
including a machete and a flint lock
pistol when Jack's crew had boarded the
vessel that Thomas was on Bonnie was
sentenced to death she had just one more
chance pleading the belly AKA claiming
to be pregnant both she and Mary Reed
did this and obtained a temporary state
of execution though Reed herself died in
prison from a fever Bonnie's fate
however is far more mysterious and
controversial many sources simply state
that they have no idea what happened to
her but that she gave birth to her child
and somehow avoided execution others are
convinced that Bonnie's father
intervened and that he somehow secured
passage for his daughter to return to
chareston where she led a quiet
unassuming life like fre of pirates but
this is largely based on one pretty iffy
account written in the 1960s hundreds of
years after it was supposed to happen so
we can't pay it too much Credence though
we do have to mention it here and we're
just going to play it safe and say that
we don't really know what happened to an
Bonny because there's no Source solid
enough for us to be willing to commit to
one version of events or another all we
will say is that like many other like
notorious historical figures and Bonnie
simply disappeared into the midsts of
History so I hope everybody at home
found this video to be educational
informative and entertaining I certainly
found the script to be all three of
those things and if you are inclined to
agree you can let the author know on
their social media links below I'm sure
Ru Alexander would love to hear from all
of you and see that number of followers
go up and up and up and up because they
deserve it they put a lot of work into
researching the scripts they read an
entire book A book who reads those
things these days so yeah give them
props for that one my social media links
are also found below and while you're
down there clicking things leave a like
comment below with feedback suggestions
like maybe other things to cover your
own favorite pirate joke and subscribe
for more content like this and I'm going
to end like oh what's the more pirate
jokes that I know
so they'll be coming everyone get ready
so most of them are just sailor jokes
where you just go at the end of them um
that's one um what kind of sailors get
all their movies for free Pirates do
what you want cuz a pirate is free you
are a pirate what happens if you steal
the pee from a pirate he becomes Pirate
no like he just a pro TI um for the guys
behind the scenes never set me up to
tell bad jokes I know so many bad jokes
we'll save them for another video video
on another time cheers
everybody